we all despised draco at times but you
know we could have liked him in the end
fortunately tom felton was nothing like
his on-screen brat here's a look at all
things tom having a laughing cry in
harry potter from magical friendships to
heart-wrenching moments we know and
didn't get to see
number one a young tom was one of more
than thousands in line trying to be a
part of the harry potter universe all of
which knew the books of harry potter
except for him as you can see
ship shape with my pot of knowledge the
audition process for harry potter took
ages to find the right kids for the
roles and when it came time for tom to
tell filmmakers which scene he wanted to
see come to life on screen
well he may have cheated a little the
guy next to me says something about
gringotts and goblins i was just like
yeah
maybe because he knew nothing he stood
out and got the part
or maybe that was just in character for
a malfoy to hate reading about potter
tom even went out for the roles of harry
and ron but we're glad they came to
their senses and cast the perfect spell
to get the right draco
number two there's nothing more magical
than having good friends at work
especially if you're able to abruptly
switch to hating them on screen there
you talk to me
filthy mud blood the two pals were
inseparable on set they teased and
goofed their way through eight long
films and with all the pressures of
being in a blockbuster franchise they
may have gotten under each other's skin
too whoops
probably not a great idea to fight in
midair though but friendships like this
last forever and it seems like neither
broke the unbreakable bro vow they still
talk from time to time i'm sure we'll
catch up over a point tonight at some
point number three you potter fans have
watched all the deleted scenes from the
films but there's one in particular with
his father lucius played by jason isaacs
that just makes us feel so much pain for
felton lucky with jason was a real treat
in this scene when draco accompanies his
loving father on a couple of errands
he's met with a sharp cane to the hand
jason felt so bad for what he did to him
but tom took it like a true champion of
slytherin he went you know so it's good
for the scene this sadly wasn't the end
of onset injuries for felton could this
have been the hidden message he failed
to see in his teacup
number four well here we go again
poor poor tom though
this time he actually asked for it come
on slap me right now let's just do this
to the emotions it was scripted that
emma watson's hermione granger would
slap draco in the scene but felton
wanted to make the hit as real as
possible we're not saying emma had
something in it for him but come on he
literally asked for it
her character certainly felt good but
deep down her love for tom made her feel
horrible i feel terrible i feel really
bad
number five
what if tom felton made a love potion
for emma watson
the most powerful love potion in the
world
just a joke but emma did reveal she had
a thing for tom on set
her first day on set sparked a big crush
for the draco actor but they remained
great friends throughout the process and
beyond we've been very good friends for
a very long time believe it or not he
may not have had anything other than
platonic feelings for her but can't you
help but notice the way he looks at her
oh look at that look at that
lucky man
number six
let's jump into that scene from goblet
of fire
you know the one
let's be real we all loved this moment
oh and just in case anyone's asking he
was not actually turned into a ferret
hope we alleviated some fears there
number seven behind the scenes of the
harry potter films tom was known as the
jokester and just the guy who always
wanted to have fun on set yeah man i've
been doing my sticks i've been working
my feet you see my feet
his onset shenanigans never got him into
too much trouble and he definitely took
his leisure time very seriously tom was
never a stranger to cracking a joke
behind the scenes but once the director
yelled action he was all in just give us
a thumbs up
number eight felton worked with some of
the greatest silver screen legends of
all time from gary oldman to the
eccentric helena bonham carter but half
the time he didn't even know who they
were i thought gary oldman was one of
the cleaners
funny enough he felt very intimidated by
alan rickman allen might have been so
good at his acting that tom just
couldn't see through snape's cold
personality i'll escort him out
he enjoyed working with all the
star-studded veterans but he has the
king liking to helen upon him carter
she seems like a lot of fun behind the
scenes and even though her character is
the epitome of evil bellatrix lestrange
is definitely the most entertaining
number nine there was a big change that
occurred in draco midway through the
films if you read the books you saw it
coming but some of us were very
surprised he took a leap he took a leap
of a few years
we got to see more of draco throughout
the second half of the films which
allowed them to show sympathy for the
character this change was a little
daunting for tom as it meant that he
would have to go from that
two-dimensional bratty kid to the evil
chosen one set to carry out the dark
lord's demands there's quite a lot to
sympathize with him in the respect that
he doesn't have a choice number 10
we need to talk about that moment
you know that moment you realize draco
breaks and almost falls to harry's wand
i know what you did malfoy
you hacked her didn't you
at this point in the franchise we never
saw the full potential of tom's acting
but he shined in the scene and worked
with multiple stunts and even survived
shattered mirrors certainly gives you a
lot more things to play with really
number 11
it was now time for tom to do the
unthinkable to do volda he who must not
be names bidding oh my god this is
pretty intense stuff we wonder what it's
like going from that boy with the
backhanded quips at potter to the
all-grown up teen choosing a side it's
unlike tom to do something so sinister
but his commitment to the role always
surpassed that don't you understand
i have to do this
he felt pretty pressured to do the scene
having a moment in front of a few
legendary actors and actresses can prove
to be very daunting but no one disagreed
felton can act
well done
number 12
felt him was finally able to get in on
the action and he was all in for it it's
the first bit of
actual
and when we say he was all in for it he
was determined to do it himself
of course it took him a few takes to
finally sell the stun
but all that matters is that it looked
wicked cool in the end smiling now only
because my feet are on the floor
number 13 let's jump into another that
moment segment we're talking about that
awkward hug from the dark lord can
barely sit stand within five meters of
him let alone him touch me we were all
probably thinking to ourselves was that
really necessary
well it actually wasn't even scripted
fines was given the opportunity to play
some of his own choices in the scene and
we guess
rivoldi just really wanted a hug
i couldn't
touch you
that awkward moment sent shockwaves on
set and who's to say that didn't
influence some of the reactions we saw
in the final product
number fourteen
still watched all the deleted scenes
then you definitely know that draco's
ending would have been drastically
different in the deathly hallows part
two really
yes really
draco was supposed to save the day and
throw harry awand and join his
classmates in the fight against evil we
were going to actually see a brave
moment from a malfoy
it's fine
it's fine
no one asked your opinion
you filthy little my blood
number 15
we all had tears in our eyes watching
the touching moments with all the cast
during the harry potter reunion
felton grew up too fast for us
quickly makes you feel slightly
older tom was given the chance to delve
into his character's greatest moments
and talk about all the fun anti-draco
things he did on set amazing that's
clearly what draco does in his spare
time number 16
tom was pretty hush-hush about being a
goof on set but once it came time to
hang up the uniform there's no
restrictions on what he could do next
there's an air of mystery about him we
don't really know what's going to happen
next
now that he's free of his contractual
obligations you know he tried to put
daniel radcliffe in the trunk of a car
fortunately he never pulled off the
prank but we're sure dan would have been
all for it wouldn't you have loved to
see the security's face when they lifted
the boot up and saw daniel lying in the
back hands tied up
what a great guy that tom is who knew he
was such a nice guy maybe he's just
doing his job then he's a really good
actor too did you think draco is cheated
from redemption in the end let us know
in the comments
[Music]